welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and in my
opinion
age of Ultron is one of the most
underrated movies in the MCU the film
had the difficult task of following the
first one which revolutionized the
comic-book movie and set the stage for
Marvel to dominate the world where
Avengers introduced the group and
established the team
age of Ultron focused mainly on
developing their character and showing
the repercussions of their actions
there's a ton of Easter eggs in the
movie and certain elements that set up
things which wouldn't pay off till much
later in the saga a binge watched the
entire MCU countless times and with all
of this information stuffed in my head
I'm here to break down some of the
insane details that you may have missed
in the movie obviously there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you still
haven't had a chance to see the film yet
then I highly suggest that you turn off
now if you enjoy the video then don't
forget to leave a like and make sure you
subscribe to never miss one without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into a breakdown of Avengers
age of Ultron
okay so age of Ultron centers around
Tony trying to prevent another attack
similar to the Battle of New York he
does this by trying to make its best
defender a quote unquote suit of armor
around the world in doing so he steps
over the mark and creates one of its
most formidable foes Ultron to me has
always come across as an extension of
toning and what the character would be
like if he didn't have restraints
holding him back Ultron reflects Tony in
several ways and laced throughout the
film is this idea of reflection that
exemplifies the struggle between the
main protagonist and antagonist this is
shown in several shots including two
statues that appear to be mirror images
of one another when the Quinjet flies by
them vision looks at himself in a
reflection overlooking New York and even
Thor at one point in the film says in
every realm there is a reflection Ultron
and Stark are extremely similar in
certain ways and this is even
exemplified in certain lines of dialogue
there's of course the obvious one that
core points out when Ultron says a star
quaver beam but there's also another
moment that reinforces this notion when
talking to Scarlet Witch in Quicksilver
Ultron says about how everyone
creates a thing that they dread he says
that people create smaller people and
then struggles with the noun before
saying children later in the film when
discussing Clint's kids Tony says and
there are smaller agents both struggle
to come to the word children and it
showcases the similarities the statement
that everyone creates the thing they
dread also foreshadows how Ultron ends
up creating vision who destroys him at
the end of the movie
Ultron also drops another line that
foreshadows things to come much later
and that is when he says when the earth
starts to settle God throws a stone at
it the Infinity stones have caused
ravaged the universe including earth and
this is a nice bit of subtext that gains
a lot of weight with the following films
another theme that is prevalent
throughout the movie is that of teamwork
their inability to work together would
lead to the rift that splits the group
in civil war Tony creates Ultron with
Bruce Banner and both refused to tell
the rest of the team when discovering
this Tony and cap have an argument in
which they talk about their mortality
and the former says will die which is
rebuffed by Kappa says then we'll die
together
this shows that Tony thinks of himself
before all else whereas cap thinks of
everyone as a team it eventually gets
resolved an end game when Tony rejoins
the team and helps them to time-travel
Tony is one of the only people an
infinity war that didn't come out a
loser because his wife survived and from
this he was able to create a family he
could have easily stayed selfish not
helped the team with the heist and lived
out the rest of his years happy however
he brushed this to the side decided to
make sacrifices and join the team
repairing the rift
and thus saved the universe it's an
awesome thing that appear and shows the
development of the character from a
selfish self-centered person into the
sacrificial hero this isn't the only
element that foreshadows and game he
there and there are actually a number of
scenes here in which the film is paid
lip service and things slowly start to
fall into place at one point in the film
when defending his actions
Tony points to the sky and says that up
there
that's the end game the look of the iron
Legion design is also extremely similar
to the quantum suits and certain aspects
and it looks like stark hurried across
many of the elements
Tony's vision at the start of the movie
has a lot of foreshadowing in it mainly
the death of the Avengers and this
pretty much sets him on the
to creating Ultron whilst most of this
scene doesn't necessarily return the
landscape does look very similar to the
final battle in endgame and there are
some other things that pop up too caps
shield eyes completely split and this is
what happens with the item during his
fight with da nose the shield itself
also foreshadows something later in the
film and that is the death of Ultron
both the shield and the way their alpha
Ultron's body is torn apart at the end
mirror each other massively and the
outline of them looks extremely similar
we almost see cap lifting Manya in the
movie and joss whedon later confirmed
that he was worthy but he didn't do it
because he didn't want to hurt those
feelings I'm not sure how I feel about
that exactly but yeah that's what the
director said in regards to that scene
during endgame we can see that natasha
has left some ballet shoes on a chair
and this is a callback to a time
training in the Red Room which we see
fleshed out in this film this appears
during a hallucination provided by
Scarlet Witch and in this scene Thor is
also affected in this vision he sees
Heimdall who greets him is the first son
of Odin this is notable because he
greets him as the first son and not the
first child which we would later learn
in Ragnarok is hella doll begins to have
a vision within a vision in which he
sees the Infinity stones for a brief
second lightning shoots from him after
this and it strikes a person turning
them to dust those killed by the
Infinity stones in infinity war two
turned to dust and I love the
consistency here after this vision door
sets out on a journey to discover the
Infinity stones he sees flashes of them
in the pool later and when he returns to
the Avengers he says I've had a vision a
whirlpool that sucks in all hope of life
and at the center of it is that this is
referring to the mind stone the mind
stone actually sits in the center of the
Infinity Gauntlet and this incredible
bit of subtext shows how far ahead
Marvel were thinking during this scene
we also see the Avengers arguing over
whether to upload javis consciousness to
Ultron in banos A's I'm in a loop I'm
caught in a time loop and this is
exactly where it went wrong this is
important as we know that far ginko had
the basic plot of the Infinity Saga
sketched out and time travel was likely
the solution that they were planning on
using to save the universe banished
States and this is where all went wrong
this shows that they could have
destroyed the main stone at that very
moment and the Stannis would not be able
to collect the stones and wipe out half
of all life in the universe there are
other notes of the movies in the film
and even a hint that the Nick Fury we
see is actually Tallis in disguise
at the end of Spider Man far from home
we discovered that Talos has been
masquerading as the character for the
entire film whilst he takes a vacation
it is possible that he has done this at
other points in his career - in Captain
Marvel we learn an obscure fact about
fury his that he can't heat toast that's
been cut diagonally in age of Ultron we
see fury tucking into a sandwich that
just so happens to be cut diagonally so
either he got over his phobia or this
was actually Tallis we also see the
Grand Central Station clock has been
replaced with a memorial to the first
responders of the Battle of New York the
original was destroyed during the fight
and thus in the Marvel Universe they had
to put something there instead door
gives Captain America some Asgardian
liquor and then when Stan Lee asks for
some he says it's not for mortal men he
was fine giving it to Steve because as
we learned in the First Avenger
Capcom get drunk Ultron wipes all of the
digital copies of The Avengers files and
that's the only way that they can learn
about klore and Strucker is through
Steve's in this series we have learned
that Steve still gets his mission
briefings on paper and thus they are
able to find things out about the
villains Ultron says that wonder will
tear the Avengers apart and in some way
she does though not in this film during
Civil War Scarlet Witch is instrumental
in the Sicari Accords being created and
these lead to the Avengers going their
separate ways the sun's going down big
guy gesture that Black Widow does is of
course a punch line using thor ragnarok
I'm sure you knew that one I'm just
being thorough thorough terrible I'm
sorry anyway as mentioned in our last
video on civil war which you should
definitely check out if you haven't war
machines chest is decorated with Ultron
skulls for all of the machines that he
killed during this movie in ant-man we
also see that on the front page of the
newspaper there's an article on the
Battle of sokovia the film of course
references a lot of other things in the
Marvel Universe and the movie is filled
to the brim with callbacks to the comic
books there's too many to mention but
some of the most obscure ones are that
we
Helen show for a big chunk of the movie
Helen is the mother of a madea's Chow
who in the comics is a version of Hulk
the Hulkbuster station is called
Veronica which is a nod to Archie comics
as Bruce's love interest at this point
was Betty and Betty and Veronica are of
course a pair in those books Ultron is
trying to make vision his ultimate form
and the back of the character's head
actually looks a lot like Ultron's face
from the comics as well though Ultron
doesn't go into this upgraded body the
upgrades that he carries out in the film
actually make a lot of sense when
fighting Captain America cap managed to
smash his chest with the shield and this
severely damages him in the final
version
Ultron's chest is reinforced to stop
this from happening again similar to
this the movie has its own references to
internal parts and arcs that are set up
and paid off later
James Spader voice is a member of the
iron Legion and he would of course go on
to voice Ultron this explains why Ultron
sounds like him and not Paul Bettany we
also see Bruce's pants in stock slab
showcasing Noddy probably worked on them
they're stretchy to fit both forms of
the character so there would need to be
some alternate development methods to
the fabric Captain America goes toe to
toe with an alternate sentry and ends up
severely damaging it we can see that the
one that vision confronts at the end
that these are the same robot due to the
shoulder cut and missing arm we also see
in the corner of Hawkeye's farm is the
target with a worn out bullseye
indicating just how good of a shot he is
when approaching the tractor Tony says
hello dear and this is because it's a
John Deere tractor and the phrase peace
in our time which is uttered throughout
the movie actually has a lot of subtext
to it this was used by Neville
Chamberlain in 1938 here in the Munich
Agreement which said that Great Britain
and Germany would not go to war similar
to the film this search for peace did
not go well and yet the MCU did it again
with an incredible number of Easter eggs
and nods to other things anyway that's
our entire list and as always with the
MCU I had a hell of a lot of fun making
this and I hope you enjoyed it too
obviously I loved hear your thoughts on
the tidbit so comment below and let me
know if you want something else to watch
then make sure you check out a breakdown
of the insane details that we noticed in
Captain America so
or as some crazy things in that so
definitely check it out after this every
month on the 15th we give away free
blu-rays and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning the Infinity
Saga box set is leave a like and
subscribe with notifications on you want
to support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button you can also
come chat to us on our discord server
link below right definition white t on
twitter those are the best ways to keep
up to date with the channel so hopefully
we see over there very soon this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thank you
for taking the time to watch this I've
been definition you've been the best
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]